like the rest of the country the people
of wakefield are adapting to the new
normal but this is a city that's now
identified as an area of concern
following a recent rise in the number of
positive tests for covid19
a possible candidate then for the
implementation of the new powers given
to local authorities
to implement local lockdown measures
they will have the powers and they will
be able to act
immediately wherever that's required so
that's a that's a matter for them
locally working with
public health england and others but the
powers will be there
health experts in wakefield say there's
no need yet for what the prime minister
calls a lightning lockdown
but are urging people to remain alert
wear face coverings in enclosed spaces
and continue following social distancing
protocols
meanwhile they'll continue monitoring
the situation
just for the last couple of weeks we've
been able to get the level of data that
we require to manage outbreaks
successfully at a local level
and my team have developed a very
comprehensive early warning system
which not only looks at postcode data
but things like
phone calls to your local gp we even
track social media coverage on that
and so that's a very robust mechanism to
ensure that we are absolutely on top of
it and we
understand if at any point we have any
concerns
although the accuracy of data given to
local authorities has been greatly
improved in recent weeks
there are calls for it to be made even
more detailed
number one is named patient data you
know a postcode can take you to a
general area
a name takes you directly to the source
of the outbreak and that enables people
to
act more um more effectively
on the ground the second is the data
comes at the moment in
weekly batches and obviously named
patient data daily would make a massive
difference
so it is getting better but we're not
there yet
in wakefield's trinity walk shopping
center one-way systems
social distancing and highly visible
messages of advice are all in place
and most of the shoppers here are happy
to see decisions being made
more locally i think councils because to
know the area
whereas boris johnson doesn't know the
area
it can go from wherever in yorkshire is
down the south
i think it's right i think local
authorities have should have this day
because every city every town have
their own needs and meeting those needs
might be different to what the
government are saying in london so okay
good yeah it's good for the local
community as well
and then they can put out the rules and
regulations
give people more safety councils in
areas with higher rates of infection
have broadly welcomed their newly
bestowed powers
but there are still concerns that being
allowed to introduce local restrictions
is one thing
being able to adequately enforce them
could be quite another fraser moored
sky news wakefield